uh i get
like it's an r-rated movie like i slice
a guy's face off with a meat slicer
i uh my dicks out for like three minutes
you can kind of see my butthole uh it's
it's
it's a hard r i get
i get like uh like little kids
i mean i haven't lately because of
covert times but i get like
children like 12 year old kids being
like
hey man gay i just want to let you know
game over man's my favorite movie
uh i watch it like with my buddies like
every night and i'm like
what dude right you watch that movie
every night jesus christ
did you did you let your mom know that
you're gonna be fully nude or did you
just wait for her to watch it
i did yeah i told her i'm i mean the
thing is
is when i shot the scene uh when i shut
when i shot this with oh just to give
some um
a reference for people that maybe
haven't seen it what are you doing go
watch it
but uh it's terrorists have taken over
the hotel we work at
we're trying to hide in a a room
and uh they're coming down the hall with
machine guns
i take my belt off and i go i got just
the plan and you're like what is he is
he gonna attack the guy with the belt
the the they come in the hotel room and
then they open up the hotel room door
and i've auto erotic affixiated myself
and and
i'm hanging in the closet as if i'm dead
holding my dick in my hands
and so that's the seed and then uh
i we i we end up fighting these guys
uh and my dick is out the entire time so
but for the premiere i told my mom
that my dick is gonna be out in the
movie and she's like oh it's not that i
haven't seen before you know she's just
a sweet midwestern woman
and and uh while she i invited
my parents to the premiere you know it's
a big deal for me and i invite them to
the premiere
and my uh when my
that scene comes and my dick is out and
i'm flapping around everywhere
uh my mom reaches over to me and grabs
my hand and goes
i'm so proud of you
[Laughter]
which is the sweetest thing i mean oh my
god
thank god thank god she's like that and
not just like you're you're a
disappointment
yeah right you're out of the family that
was uh
holding your hand at this point my
family plenty
um sir how long you been married now and
congratulations by the way i'm not i'm
not yet
copen kind of uh so you just got engaged
uh marathon engagement like me yeah how
long have you been engaged for
well it's been a year now in october
what about you steve
i've been creeping up on three years
hey just bask in the glow man
your whole life to be married right
exactly
were you with were you with your fiance
at the time that you shot game over man
yeah and how did she feel about the
schlong edge
she i mean she knew what she was getting
into
when she started you know she'd seen
workaholics she knows
she's she's familiar and and i also i
wrote the movie me and the guys wrote
the movie so
she knew she read this script and she
was like jesus christ and your dick is
going to be uh in like seven pages of
your dick
yeah and i'm like well we'll cut around
it won't just be my dick the whole time
and then in the edit bay uh kyle's just
like dude
i tried to make it so it's not your dick
the whole time but
it's really funny if your dick is just
out the whole time and i'm like well
all right and what's funny when we shot
that scene like
uh the the crew guys were so
uncomfortable
at the beginning of the day because it
was a whole big fight scene
so it took like seven hours to shoot so
they're
wildly uncomfortable these are like
grizzled
seasons you know like that or like your
dad's age just like working a camera or
a boom up and like you know
rips and [ __ ] and by the end of the day
couldn't care less so that my dick is
out there like they're actually like
coming up with better shots they're like
it'd be funny to like zoom in like down
low i think the dick will look funny
uh coming at like from this like a hero
shot
up to the dick and i'm like all right i
guess we're adding shots now
we're adding dick shots my sexy uh guy
up here paul briskey with the sexy voice
is also my editor and he has spent a lot
of time staring at my dick
oh my god that's a true lucky lucky man
i've seen yeah i've seen steve jack off
to completion from 12 angles
every frame yeah i had to throw together
your vasectomy bit in the beginning and
i was just
like four hours of staring at them cut
your balls open
yeah and uh yeah yeah
i i i had a big stunt i was so excited
about
called skyjacking where i was jacking
off i'm butt naked
in an airplane got a guy strapped to my
back and i'm whacking it for the [ __ ]
fences
and i fall out of the airplane
simultaneously blowing a load
jesus christ yeah that's why we had 12
angles
because it was awesome the world
needed it uh so you were able to i mean
that's
impressive i don't think it was it was a
logistical nightmare
yeah i brought a dvd player with me
okay so you got yourself there
by like watching porno or whatever
correct yeah now here's the [ __ ] butt
kicker
like right before we take off they say
hey dude like this needs to happen
within a very tight window of two
minutes
because if you fall out of the airplane
at any other time we're
to miss the drop zone so i'm going to
have to kind of [ __ ] thread the
needle with this one
yeah so you really you you queued up the
perfect
perfect [ __ ] scene i told them
i thought about it for a second and i
said i said okay
give me a good minutes notice give me
one minute's notice before the two
minutes
starts yeah it's smart yeah
still see that's that talent that you
didn't have to write a workaholic
my girl at one point i remember my girl
i got
saying she [ __ ] caught me just off
guard she says you know
if it really bothers me the way that
you get naked all the time you know like
with you with your dick you know i don't
like that she's like
she's like we're in an intimate
relationship and you know
i kind of feel like that's my dick i
don't like you're showing it to
everybody
sure yeah you know and you're like baby
it's the world's dick at this point this
is insured for 500 000. this is an
international
actually i think i was i i i got myself
a little bit
in a better position i said babe
whatever i do
it's a lot funnier if i got my dick out
that was it
yeah i couldn't argue with that it's a
true you can't argue with that
spiritual axiom yeah it's an immutable
law of nature
[Laughter]
so uh i want to go back um one more
thing on the day
i'm so excited now to announce that i'm
selling at my website
autographed dick pics thank you very
much
yeah that's when you got to hit him with
the horn
let's get that cheers because i have
this one bit where i'm like you know
what
women can just paint their boobs and
walk around like it's no big deal so why
can't i paint my dick
and do whatever oh i can't you're your
dick is painted
yeah you say i painted on the bike
shorts and my dicks just flopped out
[ __ ] painted black
and i go you know it's a [ __ ] dick
pic dude where can they get those
get them at stevo.com in our brand new
naughty store which you have to be 18
years old to enter
yeah yeah dude